temos sangue a produção da lenha e do
carvão vegetal efeito de uma forma
informal em que consiste no abate da
floresta natural o abate da floresta
natural consiste é cortar a água que
cresceu sozinho naquela floresta em
quando a árvore cortada ela deixa de
existir ea floresta os poucos fica de
degradar a população os americanos
consomem em média cerca de 3 milhões de
toneladas de carvão por ano e que uma
última bola sozinho resulta em uma
batida de 140 mil hectares de floresta
para sua produção
apesar da existência de outras fontes de
energia alternativas estão a desenvolver
que a eletricidade está chegando nos
distritos do país eo gás natural quem e
que é para o local que também acessível
vai levar muito tempo a toda população
moçambicana ter acesso a essas fontes de
energia por exemplo a energia elétrica é
fácil comprar o fogão mas é caro manter
a lenda da profecia o gás natural é
barato lugares mas é difícil encontrar a
botija ou a sua redistribuição ainda
está em fase de crescimento e temos aqui
nos lábios
as panelas do comer feito a cozinha
local e moçambique
usando a lenha eo carvão vegetal temos
aí o pai a fazer a pole na prova a
culinária a minha mãe eu gol de idade eu
já ia floresta do ano no distrito da
manhiça para aportarmos a lenha e ela
fabricavam carvão e este o processo de
produção conforme vemos o senhor ali com
o forno a que eu chamo de estofo
geralmente para produzir 30 sacos de
carvão leva cerca de uma semana a
queimado naquele processo tradicional
arco os adeus amigo e no caso de chuva
pode vir a levar mais dias que o
caminhão de carvão que a gente vê na
estrada ele esse com 128 a 200 sacas de
carvão e leva em média um mês para poder
encher o caminhão e sair do local do
mato para levar
o estaleiro seja no benfica onishi lenny
e por sua vez será levado todos
distribuidor para as zonas urbanas
este é um processo normal da
distribuição do carvão quando chega no
estaleiro
esse é o processo como moçambique de
transporte do carvão vegetal e os
estudos revelam que em média ou por
capita o consumo anual de 120
quilogramas isso é que cada cabeça aqui
nesta sala consome em média 120
quilogramas de carvão por ano e para
produzir 100 a 150 quilogramas de carvão
é preciso abater uma água com mais uns
30 acima de 30 centímetros do diâmetro
do seu tronco e com medo da boa ação
global o número das obras pela batida
sua produção de carvão vegetal vai
aumentando
isso levando à degradação das nossas
florestas
a água ter uma importância muito grande
para o meio ambiente ela absorve as
águas já fez dois países para evaporar
para o céu e ao mesmo tempo protege nos
da evolução do solo através das suas
raízes
a produção do carvão vegetal é feito com
abate da floresta natural
e isto sem plano de implantação do mapa
para garantir a produção do dia do
amanhã e sempre com a falta desse plano
resulta também é a destruição das nossas
florestas e aumento do custo do próprio
carvão vegetal eu visitei a província de
zambézia a 4 dias atrás onde passei pelo
rio dos bons sinais e wilma nal
aquele mangala anos atrás tinha muitas
árvores é um sofredor
elas foram acabando por pouco para a
produção do carvão vegetal e um cofre
daquelas árvores criou a destruição
daquela terra que separava a madeira
dure o do oceano e esse exemplo não é só
na província de isabela está a acontecer
em todo nosso país
esta é uma das fotografias e entre
outros fatores e outros pontos que
acontecem com a parte das águas é
apertado habilidade das várias vezes
estes animais que existem nas nossas
florestas
a luz de vocês aqui nesta sala condizer
com o sebastião
você está preocupado com a produção do
carvão vegetal sabia que a quem faz uma
dela com as nossas florestas
é verdade mas é aquele senhor que
plantar vão pra fazer na dela ele faz
dinheiro suficiente para poder pagar um
agrônomo para controlar a posição de uma
inovadora e que eles e até um beijo
espaço que eles vazio aquele senhor que
conta a madeira nas florestas
ele é registado e é fácil da cidade
localizarem para poder recordar da
necessidade de plantar de novo as águas
nas nossas florestas e casa de um de nós
aqui nesta sala tem uma cadeia uma peça
de mobília que é feito com madeira e
aquela peça exista mais de dez anos lá
em casa ou mesmo cinco anos mas o saco
de carvão que nós temos lá em casa em
casa da vovó em casa do primeiro caso da
mala não dura mais de um mês porque o
ritmo do consumo de carvão e acelerado
do que o ritmo de uma peça feita com
mandela e o processo da produção do
carnaval é muito menos de informar que o
processo de produção de mobília aquele
senhor que corta a floresta para puder
fazer o carvão vegetal
mal sabia estar menos informados sobre o
que muda um dia perguntei muda e se muda
o que significa mudar para onde afinal a
própria palavra mudança significa uma
água pequenina que você planta de novo
pra aquecer na localidade de magude uma
família receber uma água e chamado e
checados que tinha que mandar aquela
espécie e as espécies daquela água era
em vida livre da ação avançou plantas
modificadas que se adaptam às
temperaturas atuais e que existem há
certos fenômenos naturais e exige um
novo tipo de tratamento geralmente as
árvores que nós vimos nas comunidades em
moçambique elas terão sozinhas e quando
a máquina recebe uma espécie híbrida que
exige muita água pra pegar muito cuidado
para poder atingir o tamanho sustentava
o tamanho grande
ela diz
nem tenho água primeira em casa por ter
água propor neste cachoeiro que vieram
me dar
ela diz que não pediu cachoeira e da
java e distribuídas a essas comunidades
quase todas ou nenhuma chega aqui eu
esteja por falta de conhecimento
necessário para cuidá las porque foram
dados em indivíduos que não estão
capacidade não estão prontos para cuidar
de uma espécie de nó cresceu sozinho
tivemos a situação do coqueiro na
província de zambézia e bem a situação
do coqueiro em um ímã e vendo a situação
do caju a zona sul do país
a mesma coisa a única coisa que
moçambique nós sabemos legal essa laden
com outros fatores da parte das nossas
florestas
temos aquecimento global e as mudanças
climáticas ignorarmos esse ponto foi
quando a estrada destrói-se com chuva
sabemos dizer que trabalho do governo
para reparar ignorarmos esse ponto de
mudanças climáticas porque quando a
cheia chega na zona
sabemos que o trabalho de energia nos
dado não vai roubar o novo a casa é
verdadeiro e nos deram nova casa quando
crianças não choravam nossos pais nos
davam xuxa
chorávamos nossos pais nos comprar um
sorvete e crescemos com a atitude de
todos os problemas que a gente enfrentar
alguém vai resolver por nós e agora que
somos adultos quando enfrentarmos
problemas vamos de situações de
situações ou verificamos aquilo que
chamam de consultas para saber chegue
realmente se passa connosco e com o
desenvolvimento da ciência e e formação
nós já aprendemos a maioria dos assaltos
que vivemos tem as suas causas e formas
de prevenir está a acontecer agora com
problemas ambientais
quando chega às mudanças climáticas
quando chegam cheias quando chegam os
terremotos demos tendência em dizer que
uma obra divina e nós tiramos a
responsabilidade bi e no dia que nós
contamos já que lavar
fizemos parte da destruição do nosso
planeta e outro ponto dessa das mudanças
climáticas é a segurança alimentar o
aquecimento global
o aumento da temperatura no planeta
terra
as nossas plantas daquilo que a gente e
cultivava exige da informação científica
para poder se adequar a temperatura
atual vai poder se adequar o ambiente
atuais
eu próprio a concretizar o meu sonho de
ser empreendedor
voltei do estrangeiro abriu uma chapa
com as minhas poupanças do padrão de
jogo lá fora do país 12 hectares de
terra dividir feijão em alá o repúdio e
tab aqueceu bastante e depois à noite
choveu de repente e quando isso acontece
o repolho aquecem quando caiu chuva
depois cozzi
perdi quase a metade da minha plantação
e tem ainda salários por pagar
perdi o meu dinheiro o dinheiro de donos
que emprestei também está podendo mesmo
por um negócio
a única voz da aqmi possuem perfil a
esperança a quem pode dizer ou ser
bastante já falar muito eu não estou
preocupado com isso da minha casa nunca
com vendaval é quem vai dizer o sim à
questão já fala muito sobre o padroense
tem o dinheiro e comprar arroz no
supermercado não preciso de cultivar mas
nas semanas onde vocês têm um primo o
primo do primo ou alguém próximo que
dependem direta que essas mudanças podem
afetar diretamente
eu a minha vó amanheça no período de
férias a gente estava lá com cerca de 10
anos 11 anos como os irmãos caiu uma
chuva muito forte
à minha volta mas sozinho na área do
faustão já muitos anos num vôo
levantou se o teto da casa que era feito
com o pai no caniço era uma casa de
praia em nota entendemos que isso aí pra
fora da casa naquela noite para cumprir
o tempo e levamos cerca de uma semana
para repor aquela casa abrigo não
tínhamos condições
ela vivia na base do agricultor há
muitas pessoas como vovô julieta vivendo
hoje que moçambique que quando uma chuva
outro show aceita levo meses ou anos
para recuperar os seus bens
ninguém está isento
ninguém escapa ninguém é superman para
não ser atingido com os problemas das
mudanças climáticas sem falar da própria
agricultura
quando a massaroca seca ficamos com fogo
e aumenta o preço da maloca aplicar a
demanda vai ser maior
isso levanta mais o curso de vida com a
produção do próprio carvão vegetal tem
tendência a aumentar o preço
e este aumento do preço é causada no
momento do curso da sua produção
dantes produzir apontava essa lei aqui
essa é a auto-estrada e não havia gasto
de combustível e com o passar do tempo e
ver as árvores foram trabalho tinha que
contar já lá no 15 e um caminhão pensava
até lá têm mais combustível e o produtor
para chegar até lá tem mais custos de
produção e isso eleva o próprio custo do
produto final quando já chega ao
consumidor final
o carvão vegetal ea lenha sendo produtos
de primeira necessidade e quando sou o
preço sobe o custo de vida também sobe
isso afetando a todos nós e como solução
os meus colegas e eu resolvemos criar um
ecocardiograma
com o sonho no período desde anos
levamos a 0 o abate das árvores de
moçambique para a produção do
combustível
o ecocarnaval são briguet de cavar
ecoamigável que fazemos o percurso ao
lixo orgânico e cascas de coco e
biomassa dedicado então é essa minha
peça minha pequena fábrica e o carvão
pode ser usado para ganhar e para fazer
comida aquecer a água e também para
fritar é fácil e assim mesmo é produto
limpo não suja as mãos e amigável e nós
fazemos o processo de produção consiste
em apanhar o lixo orgânico carbonizados
depois de injetar nos informamos o
brinquedo 7 pedaço desse conseguem
ganhar um frango 7 pedaço desse
conseguem ferver a água cozinhar o arroz
eo nosso custo de produção por cada
pedaço e menos de 2000 e cache o
processo de produção do carnaval e do
caráter inclusivo
nós devolvemos das comunidades na sua na
cópia da matéria prima
envolvemos as comunidades no próprio
processo de produção
esse é o lixo de cana de açúcar que
usamos para produzir e também com o
oeste do lixo urbano a gente consegue
fazer os briquetes
a estoril na fábrica as estruturas
comunitárias quando a gente chega na
comunidade para recolher a matéria prima
contamos com a participação da liderança
local
a minha equipe entusiasmada em que a
maioria são raparigas e com ele o
carnaval é no período desde anos nós
levamos a 0 o abate das árvores para
produção de lenha e carvão vegetal como
é que isso vai ser possível
vai ser possível a sua vez de
empoderamento dos outros empreendedores
e dando tecnologia compartilhamos o
nosso conhecimento e criamos as 36
fábricas humano é uma outra imagem
e outra na província de zambézia e essas
três mega fábricas vão poder dar apoio
às outras microfábricas reforma de
franquias que estavam logo nas
localidades ao redor de cada província
toda a assistência técnica e todo o
conhecimento e tecnologia vai ser
compartilhado direto com os outros
pequenos empresários que fazem o mesmo
produto amigo meu sonho e objetivo da
minha equipe e eu no e monopolizar o
mercado de carvão vegetal
mas é compartilhar com os outros
empreendedores é trazer uma alternativa
sustentável para termos um moçambique
mais vendem
obrigado